- [Voiceover] The number of
mosquitos in millions, M,
so M is the number of
mosquitos in millions.
In Brooklyn, New York
it depends on the June
rainfall in centimeters, R.
So R is the amount of rainfall
measured in centimeters.
And can be modeled by the function
M, so the number of mosquitos in millions,
is equal to negative R times R minus four,
where R, once again, is the
rainfall in centimeters,
I guess in June.
Alright, fair enough.
Now let's see if we can
answer these questions.
And like always, I encourage
you to get inspired
and try to answer these
questions on your own.
(laughing) Alright, first one.
How many centimeters of
rainfall will there be...
After how many centimeters of rainfall
will there be a population
of zero million mosquitos?
Or will there be just no mosquitos?
Zero mosquitos.
Well let's just rewrite this function.
So our population of mosquitos,
it actually just helps
my brain to rewrite it,
to kind of process what's going on.
My population of mosquitos in millions
is going to be negative
R times R minus four,
where R is the number of,
the number of centimeters of rainfall.
So in order to have a
zero million population,
so that means M is going to
have to be equal to zero.
So we have to figure out at what Rs,
at what Rs is M equal to zero?
So we just have to solve
this right over here.
Well in order for this
expression right over here
to be equal to zero, notice it's
the product of two expressions.
We are multiplying, you could view it as
we're multiplying negative
R times R minus four.
Let me do R minus four
in a different color.
Times R minus four.
So if you're multiplying two
expressions and you get zero,
one or both of them need
to be equal to zero.
So let's see how that happens.
So either negative R is
going to be equal to zero,
negative R is equal to zero, or
or you're going to have R
minus four is equal to zero.
Or R minus four is equal to zero.
So how does negative R equal zero?
We divide both sides by negative one
or multiply both sides by negative one
and you get r would need
to be equal to zero.
How does R minus four equal zero?
Well you add four to both sides,
you see that R would
have to be equal to four.
So it either is no rainfall,
zero centimeters of rainfall,
or four centimeters of rainfall,
you get a population of zero mosquitos.
Now why does that,
let's just think about
whether that makes sense.
Of whether this is a good model for
for the number of mosquitos.
Well we always imagine mosquitos
need some standing water,
so if you have no rainfall,
there's not going to be
any place for them to breed.
There's not going to be
any standing water, maybe.
And the way this model seems, it's like
well if you have enough rainfall,
so some rain is gonna
help the mosquitos breed,
but then if you have enough rainfall,
they're just gonna get I
guess washed out someplace.
i guess raindrops are
gonna hit them (laughing)
as they fly, I don't know what the,
what's actually happening
at the mosquito scale,
but it's implying that if
there's a lot of rainfall
it would actually be hard.
I guess you don't have
standing water any more.
The water is moving
around and is overflowing
and it's going into the
gutter and whatever else.
It would make it vey hard
for the mosquitos to breed.
What is the maximum possible
number of mosquitos?
So the very idea that
they're asking us a maximum
implies that this quadratic over here,
and it is a quadratic and we'll see that
more clearly in a few seconds,
is shaped like this in order
to have a maximum point.
Because if it was shaped like this,
it would have a minimum point,
it wouldn't have any one maximum.
And because we have
this negative out here,
that makes us pretty confident
it is going to be a
downward opening parabola.
But to understand what
this maximum point is,
let's write it in vertex form.
Just as a reminder what
vertex form would be,
it would be writing it in the form of M
is equal to
A times R minus
B squared, plus C.
This right over here would be vertex form
and it's very useful
because you get a sense
of when you hit a
minimum or maximum point.
If thing right over here is negative,
then the maximum value,
because this thing can only be
non-positive, the maximum
value would be this,
and then we could figure out
when does this equal zero?
And that's when you
hit that maximum value.
And if any of this seems foreign,
I encourage you to watch the videos
on vertex form.
And I'm about to complete
the square on this character
in order to get here, so I encourage you
to also watch the videos
on completing the square.
So let's do that.
So let's start with this expression
and I'm gonna start by,
actually, let's start by,
I'm gonna just distribute the R.
So if you have M
is equal to, I'm gonna keep
the negative out front,
but I'm gonna distribute the R.
R times R is R squared.
R times negative four is minus four R.
And I want to complete the square.
And once again, I encourage
you to watch those videos
if what I'm about to do seems like voodoo,
but to complete the square I want
to add and subtract the same thing.
I don't want to actually change the value
of the expression.
And so I'll look at this coefficient,
this first degree coefficient
here, it's negative four.
Half of that is negative two.
If I square it, I want to add four.
I want to,
I want to add four.
I want to add,
let me make it a different color.
I want to add four.
Now once again, I can't just go around
adding numbers to expressions and assuming
the equality still holds.
I have to add and subtract the same thing.
While you might be tempted
to write a minus four
out here, because hey, I added four
and then I subtract four.
But remember, when I add this
four in this parentheses,
i have this negative out front.
If I were to distribute this negative,
I essentially, this is a minus four.
So if I wanted to add them out to be zero,
distribute this negative,
this would be a negative four.
If I wanted to cancel out
this, this needs to be
a positive four.
So once again, when
you look superficially,
it looks like I just added four twice,
but I didn't.
this right over here since
it has this negative sign,
is a negative four.
Negative four plus four is zero.
I have not changed the
value of this expression.
But anyway, now that I've done that,
this piece right over here,
the whole reason why I added four
is to make it a perfect square,
this is now the same thing as R minus two,
R minus two squared.
I have the negative out front.
We have M equals negative
R minus two squared
plus four.
Plus four.
And just like that, I've
written it in vertex form.
So what's the maximum number of mosquitos?
Well let's just look at the structure
of this expression a little bit.
This piece,
this piece right over here,
that thing,
actually, let me not do it in
the same color as the four,
let me do it in this orangish color.
This piece right over
here is always going to be
less than or equal to zero.
So that's always going to be less than
or equal to zero.
It's always going to be non-positive.
And so this whole expression
hits a maximum value
when this thing is zero,
because at any other point,
it's gong to just take away
from this right over here.
So you hit a maximum value when this
is equal to zero.
When negative R minus two
squared is equal to zero.
Well that's going to happen when,
well you can see when R
minus two is equal to zero.
Or when R is equal to two.
And when R is equal to two,
what is M going to be equal to?
Well when R is equal to two, this is zero
and M is equal to four.
R equals two and M is equal to four.
So what's the maximum possible number
of mosquitos?
Well M equals four, it's gonna
be four million mosquitos.
Remember, M is measuring in millions.
Four million mosquitos.
And then they ask us after how
many centimeters of rainfall
will the maximum number
of mosquitos occur?
Well, we figured it out.
After two.
After,
after two centimeters.
Two centimeters of rainfall.
So if we go back to our,
if we go back to our model,
at zero rainfall you have no mosquitos,
then as it rains more and more,
you have more and more mosquitos.
I guess more and more standing water.
You have a maximum number of mosquitos
at two centimeters of rainfall.
At two centimeters we have
four million mosquitos,
but after that I guess the
rain starts washing away
the mosquito eggs or something
and you start having
fewer and fewer mosquitos
all the way until you get to
four centimeters of rainfall.
And I guess after four
centimeters of rainfall,
in theory you have
negative mosquitos, I guess.
I don't know what that would mean,
and that might just be a situation
where the model just breaks down.
You obviously, I don't know what negative
million mosquitos would actually mean.
The relevant,
the relevant area where
this model should hold
is between zero centimeters of rainfall
and four centimeters, because after that
the model starts describing
negative values for M.
So anyway, hopefully you
found that interesting.